satellit übermacht flüchtlinge bei die
leiche unter bischof gefunden und
galaxien fressen galaxien das sind drei
der fünf themen heute bei den klicks und
tabloid news
im april 2014 macht es ja ne rakete für
das 6 milliarden euro schwere projekt
kopernikus auf dem weg ins all vom
weltraumbahnhof kourou in
französisch-guyana startete jetzt vor
kurzem eine neue rakete mit einem neuen
satelliten ins all
bis 2021 will die europäische kommission
und die esa zehn satelliten vom typ
sentimental schicken
die tonnen schweren satelliten sollen in
einer höhe von fast 800 kilometer daten
liefern daten die es ermöglichen sollen
den ursprung der umweltkrise zu finden
mit anderen klima relevanten daten
werden diese dann verknüpft und
analysiert quellen der anderen daten
können beispielsweise messungen von
flugzeugen oder wetterstationen seien
experten raufen sich durch das projekt
katastrophe möglichst schnell zu
erkennen
und gegen diese zu steuern
beispielsweise könne man leicht
herausfinden warum eine ernte schlechter
ausgefallen ist wenn ähnliche anzeichen
wiederzuerkennen sind kann sich die
landwirtschaft mit den daten rechtzeitig
vorbereiten beziehungsweise ganz andere
wege einschlagen einen politischen
vorteil könnte das projekt aufbringen
die beobachtung von städten und deren
entwicklung deren wachstum zb
ausbreitung struktur etc wäre um einiges
einfacher und übersichtlicher der
unternehmensebene der landwirtschaft
ebene und der wissenschaft ebene werden
diese daten frei zugänglich gemacht und
das lockt kritiker an kritiker des
projekts haben starke bedenken bezüglich
der nutzung dieser daten grenz
überwachungen würden ein leichtes spiel
werden und auch flüchtlingsströme könne
man ganz einfach erkennen und beobachten
wie die politik unternehmen und so
weiter diese daten dann verwenden wird
verwenden wird bleibt also noch
abzuwarten
zu hoffen bleibt dass diese daten
vertraulich und vor allem friedlich
genutzt werden
zugegeben das klingt erstmal sehr
skurril aber forscher konnten in einem
sarg folgendes finden
eine babyleiche war unter den füßen
eines toten bischofs versteckt bischof
wiens truppe ist vielen wissenschaftlern
ein begriff er gilt als best erhaltene
mumie in ganz europa seit rund 350
jahren liegt der leichnam des mannes in
der kathedrale in lohnt in schweden
experten besuchen immer wieder das
graben forschungen zu betreiben jetzt
stieß man bei solchen auf etwas sehr
ungewöhnliches die forscher berichteten
dem begehren über ihren fund bei neu
gemachten röntgenaufnahmen des ganzen
sagt entdeckten die forscher auf höhe
der füße einen fötus warum hat man
diesen noch nicht früher gefunden wenn
so viele forscherin strip untersuchen
da sag es mit einer großen menge an
kräutern gefüllt und somit in einem sehr
unübersichtlichen zustand der fotos seit
zirka ein halbes jahr alt geworden und
landete auch noch nicht bekannten grund
im sarg des bischofs obwohl schon im
siebzehnten jahrhundert das zölibat
gegolten hat schließen die
wissenschaftler eine direkte
verwandtschaft zwischen bischof und dem
kind nicht aus vorangegangene
untersuchungen zeigen dass der bischof
einen sehr exzentrischen exzentrisches
leben führte fertiges und sehr
zuckerhaltiges essen name zu sich also
zeichen für ein leben im überfluss
eine dna-analyse soll die frage nach der
möglichen vaterschaft spd innsbruck
klären
vor drei jahren gab es schon einmal eine
zeitumstellung die nicht mit sommerzeit
und winterzeit einhergehen 2012 wurde
die uhr umgestellt um sie an die
veränderte erdrotation anzupassen
änderung einer sekunde
am kommenden dienstag ist es wieder
soweit wer zufällig um 1 uhr 59 und 59
sekunden server zeit beobachtet wird
diese zeitangabe zweimal sehen doch
warum in einer pariser sternwarte konnte
man vor ein paar tagen auffälligkeiten
in der erdrotation feststellen folge
eine sogenannte schaltsekunde muss
eingeschleust werden
unser 24 stunden system läuft der
erdrotation etwas davon zwar nur eine
sekunde
aber dennoch sind wir etwas schneller
unterwegs als die erde wenn sie sich
einen großen zeiger vorstellen der aus
der erde ragt und als ziffernblatt im
himmel fällt die abweichung tatsächlich
auf so wolfgang beck vom central
rodas erdrotation dienstes in frankfurt
am main diese schaltsekunde geld
vielleicht sehr unspektakulär hat aber
2012 für jede menge chaos gesorgt server
waren stundenlang nicht mehr
funktionstüchtig eine folge solcher
lahmgelegten server war dann in
australien sind flüge ausgefallen
beziehungsweise wiesen gewaltige
verspätungen auf weil die flugpassagiere
zum teil analog einen tag mussten
im gegensatz zu vielen unternehmen kann
google entspannt auf diese zeit zurück
blicken
sie schoben ihrem system die
schaltsekunde unbemerkt unter auf 60
minuten verteilt nahmen sie immer wieder
kleine zeit änderungen vor
das system brach nicht zusammen seit
jahren streiten sich experten darum ob
man einer solchen sekunde derartige
beachtung schenken sollte amerika möchte
das ganze schaltsekunden theater
loswerden
russland und großbritannien möchte die
schaltsekunden umstellung weiterhin
vornehmen und deutschland wir wollen
keine technischen probleme durch
schaltsekunden erzeugen sagte vieth wolf
der sprecher der bundesnetzagentur in
bonn
deutschland steckt noch mitten in den
überlegungen die größte sekunden
umstellung wurde übrigens 1972 getätigt
ganze zehn sekunden korrigierte man
damals in jedem lehrbuch werden wenn es
um die dna geht folgende bausteine genau
aufgelistet
cgt im fachmagazin nature chemical
biology haben britische
molekulargenetiker nun ein bisher als
zwischenprodukt geltenden bausteinen
sozusagen befördert 5 fc so heißt der
baustein 5 fc steht für 5 vorne zu
ziehen und stammt vom dna baustein ccc
75 fc wurde schon vor mehreren jahren
entdeckt wurde aber nie als
langfristiger baustetten angesehen man
ging davon aus dass fünf fc temporär
existent ist beispielsweise beim
entstehen der dna für was fünf franzosen
verantwortlich ist oder zuständig ist
können die wissenschaftler noch nicht
konkret sagen vermutungen darüber jedoch
kursieren beispielsweise glaubt man dass
fünf fcn an und ausschalter für gene ist
impulse für andere biomoleküle gibt und
vielleicht sogar schuld an manchen
krankheiten ist das forscherteam wird
der frage jetzt nachgehen
die galaxie m87 ist eines von vielen
raubtieren im weltall
sie ist von uns etwa 50 millionen
lichtjahre entfernt und verspeist
offenbar andere galaxien forscher des
max-planck-instituts für
extraterrestrische physik konnten spuren
von einem solchen schauspiel finden in
den gas füllen der galaxie konnten sie
spurenelemente von anderen sogenannten
planetarischen nebel finden so
kompliziert das klingt zu kompliziert
ist es auch dass galaxien andere
galaxien fressen ist nichts
ungewöhnliches ungewöhnlich aber ist
dass der nachweis dafür existiert wie
gesagt kompliziert die europäische
südsternwarte eso in garching bei
münchen erklärt so dass etwas
unkomplizierter genauso wie sich wasser
das aus einem glas in einem teich
gegossen wird schnell mit dem teich
wasser mischt mischen sich die sterne
der galaxie die verschlungen wird mit
den ihnen sehr ähnliche stern der
größeren galaxie ohne auch nur
irgendeine spur zu hinterlassen
damit ihr eine ungefähre großen
vorstellung von dem teich m87 habt erst
im moment fünf mal so groß wie unsere
milchstraße dieser einverleibung vorgang
und diese beachtliche größe zeigt den
forschern dass selbst derartige
gewaltige galaxien noch lange nicht am
ende ihres wachstums sind der wachstum
von galaxien gehört wahrscheinlich mit
zu einem der vielen rätsel der
wissenschaft und zehn weitere rätsel der
wissenschaft geht es wie du hier oben zu
rap und zum blog geht es hier unten und
was sagt ihr zu dieser schaltsekunden
zeitumstellung brauchen wir sowas oder
ist das totaler blödsinn diskutiert es
doch mal in den kommentaren und damit
noch ein schönes wochenende und bis dann